from the meaning behind Ken's flashy fur
coat to the purpose of a pooping dog
let's explore all the subtle jokes and
references tucked away in the Barbie
movie one of the cool elements that
director Greta Gerwig brings to the film
is calling attention to the specific
kinds of Barbies each character
represents Margot Robbie's stereotypical
Barbie look doesn't outshine other
Barbies like Issa Ray's president Barbie
or Kate McKinnon's hilarious weird
Barbie hi I'm weird Barbie I am in the
splits I have a funky haircut and I
smell like basement however what really
attracts the audience's interest are the
discontinued Barbie dolls which Gerwig
includes to pay homage to both the
triumphs and mistakes of Mattel's ideas
for example Michael Sarah plays Ken's
best Buddy Alan who was discontinued
after Mattel realized that kids were not
even that interested in playing with Ken
let alone his sidekick there are no
multiples of Alan he's just Alan yeah
confused about that additionally Emerald
Fennell plays the often forgotten Midge
who is a discontinued pregnant doll you
can see other Infamous discontinued
dolls like video girl Barbie Who
functioned as a working video camera and
earring magic Ken who has an earring and
a big round necklace one scene that was
featured in the first trailer and opens
the film is the little girl's revolt
against baby dolls with Helen Mirren
narrating the scene is cinematically
gripping in it young girls solemnly play
with their baby dolls and act as mothers
while mirin tells the audience how
little girls were always force-fed the
baby doll that is until Barbie came on
the scene showing little girls that the
role of mother was not the only
aspiration they could have as a result
of seeing Robbie's powerful stance the
little girls smash their baby dolls and
revolt against this motherly ideology to
opt for a Barbie the scene might seem
slightly off-putting to those who
haven't seen the original Source
material but the Barbie opening is
entirely based on the opening from 2001
A Space Odyssey however ever instead of
an alien monolith appearing before a
crowd of cavemen Robbie's beautiful
1950s swimsuit clad presence dominates
the scene the young women are inspired
by Robbie's Barbie and instead of
breaking skulls like the cavemen do the
little girls smashed their baby dolls in
the same intense animalistic manner a
baby doll is thrown into the air before
transitioning into the Barbie logo a
clear homage to Stanley Kubrick's famous
match shot in 2001 A Space Odyssey that
turns a flying bone into a satellite the
entire scene is absurd in these
circumstances but manages to cover a lot
of exposition to contextualize Barbie
for the audience
one of the key elements to perfecting
the Barbie movie comes from recreating
the doll's iconic looks costume designer
Jacqueline Duran wanted to fully capture
the history of the doll by recreating
some of the most memorable and Niche
costumes for casual fans and super fans
alike to enjoy the designer started with
the very first look you see Robbie's
Barbie wearing the 1959 Barbie swimsuit
this look is featured in the 2001 A
Space Odyssey parody opening scene with
Robbie sporting a black and white
one-piece swimsuit red lipstick and
Sharp sunglasses the recreation of this
look is almost identical to the earliest
model of the Barbie doll it makes sense
to start the film off with Barbie's
origin and Duran absolutely Nails it if
you are anywhere on the internet then
you've probably seen the video of Ryan
Gosling at 12 years old dancing in an
episode of Star Search he stands front
and center with a group of dancers and
absolutely tears it up for the whole
audience to see the MC Hammer pants the
facial expressions and everything else
about the video is incredible and
totally on brand however nothing could
prepare you for Gosling's song and dance
moves in the Barbie movie Gerwig truly
leaned into the hype surrounding
Gosling's resurfaced video and created a
musical Masterpiece Ken sings about his
meaningless existence giving the
audience more insight into Barbie's male
accessory this musical number is a great
callback to Gosling's younger days and
gives the movie more of a quirky tone if
that's even possible no one rests until
stall is back in a box Barbie has many
sidekicks including siblings friends and
of course Ken however Barbie also has
several pets including a Golden
Retriever named Tanner one of the quick
little moments in the Barbie movie that
you might miss is the inclusion of
Barbie's dog Tanner when Barbie goes to
weird Barbie's house she finds the dog
walking through the house and leaving
poop pellets along the way the dog is
only present for a few seconds but real
Barbie fans recognize it right away one
Barbie toy that was discontinued was
Tanner an accompaniment for potty
training Barbie when Barbie would walk
the dog it would drop poop pellets and
Barbie would have the tools to pick them
up the problem though was that the
pellets were so small that they
constituted a choking hazard for small
children Additionally the toy was
recalled because the small magnet in the
scooper fell off way too easily
providing yet another safety issue for
kids this toy is one that lives in
infamy but is certainly a hilarious
addition to the Barbie movie
there are many Barbie Universe
references throughout the film and
pretty much every single one of them is
called out by Helen mirren's narration
however because of all of them it seems
especially jarring when the reference is
unrelated to Barbie fans will notice the
discussion surrounding Pride and
Prejudice and The Feminine right to
watch it whenever they want there's also
the brief discussion about loving Zack
Snyder's Justice League cut and the
masculine urge to shove that in
everyone's face however there are some
quirkier and more subtle references too
like weird Barbie offering Barbie the
truth or a way to ignore everything with
a high heel and a Birkenstock this is a
nod to the red pill and blue pill
decision from The Matrix or in the
Montage sequences there are brief clips
from The Godfather Greece and other
popular pieces of media so it's great to
watch Gerwig give both subtle and
blatant nods to popular culture
can we get some Applause for Ken's
outfit choices throughout the film most
of the focus and costume conversations
surrounding the film comes from Barbie's
looks and rightfully so however the
choices for Ken's outfits are just as
incredible did you bring your
rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them and
keeping with the theme of making
numerous pop culture references
throughout the film there are many
references to Sylvester Stallone and two
Rocky as a whole they are mostly subtle
but the biggest reference comes from
Ken's outfit Choice when he takes over
Barbie land with the patriarchy in tow
his giant white fur coat and no shirt
make for a bougie look and a reference
Sylvester Stallone wore that white fur
coat in the 70s and 80s even earning
himself a GQ article about it Gosling
learns about the patriarchy horses and
Stallone in the real world and takes all
of that including Stallone's fashion
choices back to Barbie land with him
though the coat in the film is fake for
a costume designer Jacqueline Duran said
that they lined it with horse print as
an homage to Ken's obsession with horses
for those who are fans of Stallone and
appreciate Ken's love of horses the code
is a nice little Easter egg
there is one particularly beautiful
scene in the movie that features Barbie
telling an older woman at the bus stop
that she is beautiful the woman in
response says she knows it giving Barbie
a nice smile the scene perfectly
encapsulates what the Barbie movie is
all about and it is one of the most
heartfelt moments in the film however
fans began speculating who the woman is
and many were led to believe it was
Barbara Handler daughter of Barbie
inventor Ruth Handler pump the brakes
though because that woman actually is
not Barbara Handler instead the woman in
question is actually oscar-winning
costume designer Anne Roth the scene is
still particularly meaningful but does
not have the connection to the Handler
family that many fans speculated however
there is a big mention of Barber Handler
and the way she inspired Ruth to create
the Barbie doll so she is not totally
absent from the film
though Barbara Handler was not actually
featured in Barbie Gerwig found a way to
put her mother Ruth Handler in the film
gerwig's cool way of paying homage to
Barbie's inventor is by having Rhea
Perlman play Ruth in the film this is
not just a glorified Cameo either
Handler and Barbie have a nice
conversation at the end of the film
about humanity and their relationship
with one another however the inclusion
of Handler featured a couple of quick
jokes regarding Handler's tax evasion
which fans might not understand in the
1970s handler was indicted after charges
of Fraud and false reporting to the
Securities and Exchange Commission were
brought to light she pleaded no contest
and was fined 57 thousand dollars in
addition she had to serve 2 500 hours of
community service because there were no
serious consequences it is something
people feel comfortable joking about
which is why Gerwig used it as a quick
quip in the film
[Music]
Greta Gerwig is able to explore many
themes in the film particularly about
feminism coping with existence and
trying to find your individuality in a
world that demands you to be perfect
however one more subtle theme that
Gerwig tackles throughout the movie
comes from her exploration of the way
Barbie and Ken are attached to one
another and toucan is without Barbie
coming with you okay a lot of the film
revolves around Barbie's crisis with who
she is and what she was made for
meanwhile Ken's crisis in the film is
learning about how he can be his own
person and exist as something other than
an extension of Barbie it functions as
an interesting take on the creation myth
in Genesis and how their relationship is
like Adam and Eve but flipped Barbie was
invented as a way of empowering women as
a result Ken was created after Barbie to
essentially function as a human
accessory to her just as Eve was created
after Adam furthermore Gerwig also found
a way to play on the concept of Eve
being created from Adam's Rib the
director emphasizes this in Reverse with
Barbie and Ken showcasing how Ken was
created from Barbie's Fame game though
most of the Barbie movie Focus comes
from Robbie and Gosling's performances
it's important to acknowledge how
incredible the entire cast is
particularly America Ferreira she
perfectly encapsulates what it is like
to be a woman and the intense pressure
women are under to successfully make it
through even one day her acting is
lovely and her obsession with Barbie is
relatable but we're not here to talk
about that we're here to talk about the
quick little line that references one of
ferreira's older iconic films gotta Kick
It Up ferreira's character Gloria has to
help Barbie get Barbie land back from
the cans meanwhile her husband is
learning Spanish to better connect with
his wife and daughter and says SI SE
puede to Barbie at the end of the film
though the comment is one of
encouragement essentially meaning you
can do it it is more of a nod to gotta
Kick It Up which is alternately titled
SI SE puede the reference could also
extend to Ferreira and Eva Longoria's
digital lifestyle Community for Latin
people called shise puede
foreign